the spectators podcast now have a
newsletter sign up for free at spectator
current UK forward slash podcast
- highlights to get the spectators
podcast highlights in your inbox every
Monday
hello and welcome to spectator outloud
I'm a freshman in this week's extracts
were asking leme Halligan to read out
his piece about quantitative easing and
the dangers while Shriver to discuss the
vanity of whites guilts and he sends him
acts to grin on the petals facing choirs
first Liam Halligan the footsie 100
index of leading stocks is over 20
percent up since Britain went into
lockdown that's bull market territory
the government borrowed 55 billion
pounds in May nine times more than the
same month last year yet borrowing costs
are down with some investors now paying
to lend to an increasingly indebted
nation who cares if the UK economy will
shrink some 10% this year as our
national debts Rockets over a hundred
percent of GDP stocks are up bond prices
are up and the laws of economics have
been suspended it's different this time
and all because of quantitative easing
back in 2009 with the global banking
system on the brink of collapse
QE was a justifiable emergency measure
but this one off post crisis necessity
has now morphed into a lifestyle choice
for a decade since the financial crisis
QE has pumped up share prices and
suppressed bond yields allowing
governments to borrow cheaply but to
state spending has surged post kovat
we've become dependent QE is now the
economic equivalent of crack cocaine
originally a 50 billion pound temporary
rescue measure the Bank of England egged
on by city finances and high spending
politicians expanded QE over ten years
to around 450 billion pounds since March
it's ballooned again into a seven
hundred and forty five billion pound
binge with our central bank now buying
government debts twice as fast as in
2009 ten the combined balance sheets of
the Federal Reserve in America the
European Central Bank in the Bank of
Japan has similarly swollen since kovat
by a third over the past three months
so qyz now
bloom everyone's doing it much of our
political and media class has indeed
concluded that interest rates are low
and will stay low so the government's
can keep borrowing debt service costs
are manageable is now part of the West
mr. lingo but what if the bond markets
rebel and market interest rates spike
whatever the Bank of England says and
does the immediate problem is that QE is
deeply counterproductive housing
economies with liquidity doesn't make
them grow faster that's like trying to
get fat by buying a bigger belt earning
no interest on savings and being paid to
borrow also distorts basic economics
central bank bond buying has kept far
too much capital locked up in
over-indebted zombie companies -
resulting in low productivity this
monetary excess has made financial
investors more reckless with markets
losing their ability to correct
witnessed sky-high valuations amid
crushing growth that's astonishingly
dangerous setting us up for collapse
many real-world investors meanwhile
business owners and those taking direct
stakes in companies have been so spooked
by this monetary madness that they're
keeping money off the table stymieing
growth even more but QE hasn't led to
inflation its acolytes say and it won't
in the future oh but it has much of the
central banks funny money has so far
stayed within the financial system
generating stock and bond market bubbles
as well as bloating property prices and
if bank lending now expands across the
broader economy as the government hopes
inflation will follow QE as night
follows day by holding back bond market
vigilantes for now QE is facilitating
vast government debts that will come
back to haunt us
monetary policy is now so deranged that
around 1/5 of all global debt has a
negative yield retarding global growth
and storing up huge systemic dangers
amid already massive monetary expansion
the Westminster city consensus
is that we need even more as the Bank of
England prepares to yank UK interest
rates deep into negative territory yet
sterling is not a reserve currency and
we have a huge trade deficit this cannot
end well
our QE stock markets bond market Ponzi
scheme must be recognized for what it is
we need to break our QE dependency and
encourage others to do the same what's
needed is a retreat from this monetary
frenzy calling financial markets in a
bid to restore normality and balance as
the post Kovach global economy reboots
that was leme Halligan now Lionel
Shriver when I was about 10 on returned
home from church I ate a peach the juice
of which dribbled down my new pink frock
i scuttled to my room to change bunching
the dress under the bed I emerged the
picture of innocence but I felt guilty
for weeks the garment pulsed with
accusation going to sleep I always knew
it was there sure enough my mother
discovered the wad while vacuuming and
she was furious
she could have scrubbed out the Jews had
I told her about it right away to this
day I'm mindful that you can only
expunge stains while they're still fresh
and somewhere in there lurks a metaphor
I'm not prone to remembering the
ingestion of individual pieces of fruit
that small memory looms as a touchstone
for the experience of culpability I'd
not acted responsibly and I'd compounded
my malfeasance with concealment when
called out I hung my head with nothing
to say for myself the last thing I felt
inclined to do was tear outside and
advertise to the whole neighborhood that
I've been a bad little girl though the
concept of collective white guilt has
been with us since at least the 1960s it
seemed quite the fashionable resurgence
in the wake of the George Floyd protests
month as universities businesses and
celebrities fall all over themselves to
banner their racial blameworthiness
pale-faced Mayacamas
gather into a deafening chorus the
issues are to first one of this columns
running themes emotional fraudulence
clarion declarations of moral
dereliction do not have the texture of
guilt they are prideful they have the
texture of preening elaborate racial
apologies are a form of showing off when
last month the actress Jenny slate
resigned from the animated Netflix show
big mouth because voicing a half-black
character was an example of white
privilege and an active erasure of black
people within a system of societal white
supremacy she wasn't making a career
sacrifice but bidding for elevated
status that it works to bet the lady
isn't short if work for long
fYI a backhanded boast of my own my
latest novel anticipates white audio
book readers and voiceover artists being
forbidden the mimicry of speaking as
non-white characters the prescience is
depressing we're witnessing the
spectacle of white people frantically
competing with other white people over
who can appear more self excoriating
more self-loathing but these people
don't hate themselves they hate other
people mythical other people for the
most part all those terrible racist
white folks to whom they can feel vastly
superior now that white silence equals
violence they can also feel superior to
regular going about their business white
people who haven't managed to get
prostrate pronouncements of self disgust
on BuzzFeed
these confessions are also defensive
their diversionary and an attempt to
opt-out they translate as you don't want
to come for us we're on your side we're
allies we're the nice white people and
because there's no such thing as nice
white people that means we're not really
white after all so you don't want to
burn down our premises right you want to
go for those horrible white people over
there here take some petrol and matches
on us and we won't call the cops honest
you ask Adam répertoire forced to resign
as editor of Bon Apetit over an ancient
brown face the opt-out doesn't work you
get cancelled anyway when your unseemly
black lives matter groveling is deemed
insufficiently pious proper guilt feels
bad it's emotional cousin shame feels
even worse
whenever I leaked a bit because I didn't
want to come in from playing outside my
mother forced me to wash out my panties
by hand in the sink in front of my
brothers
behold shame adult examples of shame in
my life I'd be reluctant to share here
shame is soul destroying the stuff of
suicide you don't parade shame in public
you're unlikely to leave the house so
none of the last month's white
protestors was ashamed it's you two
we're in danger of installing heritable
guilt as morally valid now that we're to
embrace the concept of an in a radical
systemic racism while employees take
mandatory courses on unconscious bias
bigotry is no longer a sin we choose or
refuse to perpetuate but a stain handed
down through the generations that's just
as indelible as the peach
juice on my pink dress is this what we
want really will we stick modern
Mongolians with the rampages of Genghis
Khan hold some 19 year old muscovite
today responsible for Stalin's gulags
force Germans to keep expiating their
little hearts out over the second world
war in the year 3000
maybe we should enlarge the lens frankly
I'm weary of the whole category white
people which throws folks of wildly
different backgrounds from Russians to
Jews to Scots into one big
indiscriminate pot so let's talk about
people full stop as a species we've been
treating each other like [ __ ] from the
year dot the horrors to which we've
subjected one another including slavery
but a great deal else our so in
comprehensively dreadful that no one as
an individual could conceivably bear the
crushing weight of all that torture mass
murder and sadism
if guilt is inherited then every last
one of us should be condemned to Dante's
nine circles of hell none of us chose
the world in which we emerged we didn't
pick our race sex or natal nationality
any inbuilt leg up or disadvantage these
traits conferred at Birth was not of our
making we didn't select which awful
history soaks the ground at our feet
it's insensible to feel guilty or
ashamed about something you didn't do
it's entirely sensible to feel regret
sorrow and up Horan's about the likes of
slavery it's commendable to be informed
about the past and to try to understand
the nature of its wretchedness as it's
also commendable to strain to leave the
world a little better than you found it
but claiming that what happened before
you were born is all your fault
it's not only ridiculous it's vain that
was Lionel Shriver now you send a Maxton
green Britain's choirs are facing
oblivion yet they're also terrified of
returning one story explains why picture
this innocent choral society seen in
Skagit County Washington states on the
evening of the 10th of March one hundred
and twenty singers most of them elderly
Sopranos gathered in the Presbyterian
Church to rehearse for two hours that
chairs 15 centimeters apart at halftime
Lee took a break for shared snacks and
at the end the helpful one stayed to
stack the chairs fifty-two of those
singers came down with Kovac 19
supposedly through release of aerosol
droplets in the ether thus began the
swirling of rumors across the world
about the grave dangers of singing it is
still not lifted in spite of the pleas
of choral directors but it was a finger
food and the chair stacking rather than
the singing that spread the disease and
that those people were old whereas many
Cathedral choirs have no one over the
age of 40 and that if you hold a candle
flame in front of a well-trained singer
the play will not even flicker so
controlled is his or her breath this
week in an operating theater at the
government science facility at Porton
down a small group of guinea pig choral
singers some professional and some
amateur are taking part in experiments
to measure what happens to those
aerosols droplets measuring five
thousandths of a millimeter or less when
they are emitted by the singing voice
similar experiments are going on in
London conducted by Declan Costello a
consultant surgeon specializing in the
human voice who also happens to be a
tenner in polyphony and the host singers
a lot is resting on these experiments he
tells me if the result is not what we
want to hear
well at least public health England can
make a decision based on the science at
the moment we have no real data it's not
a situation that ever needed to be
studied I dread to think what will
happen if the results are bad it was
grim enough on Sunday to see the Dean of
York presiding from behind a plastic
visor and holding up the wafer wearing a
blue latex glove if our nation signs
prefix become armed with new anti
singing data
there'll be no communal choral singing
for months or years and the absurd
situation could arise in
shorter allowed to sing at school which
they are in groups of up to 15 but not
in cathedrals with a vast interior
spaces meanwhile choristers voices are
breaking the rhythm of daily Psalm
singing has been halted and a drool of
britain our world's leading choral
tradition is in danger of being damaged
irreparably such as the blunt instrument
to the furloughing scheme that many
directors of music haven't even been
allowed to conduct zoom rehearsals with
their choristers as all work is
forbidden on to the scheme even
supportin down results a good will cadiz
will still be able to fund their choirs
York Minster has had to close its
Minster school with immediate effect the
Dean explained that because of the sharp
drop in tourist numbers owing to the
virus the cathedrals expected annual
income of 9.4 million will have a
shortfall of 5.2 million thankfully the
choristers would all go to some Peters
school ten minutes walk away so the news
is not quite as bad as it seems
that kind of financial shortfall will be
replicated in all cathedrals the
worst-hit being the ones that raked in
money from charging entry to tourists as
choirs cost a minimum of two hundred and
fifty thousand pounds a year to run one
can imagine belt-tightening Dean's and
chapters making small tweaks such as
lowering the number of cruel services
per week or cutting the numbers of paid
back row singers heart sank this week at
the new sets of Margaret's Westminster
and Holy Trinity Sloane Street I have
both disbanded their professional choirs
disband abolish these are the new
chilling words members of congregations
were seen dabbing their eyes on Sunday
so moved were they to be back in their
local Cathedral under the new rules
Sarris is allowed but you have to book a
slot and no hymns the permissive music
is organ plus one solo singer even that
small gesture of live music felt like a
luxury Cathedral music has returned to
the pre veticon
to sound organ verses alternating with
lines of solo plain song unsung heroes
are doing their best to save the
situation
Peter wood chairman of Friends of
Cathedral Music launched the Cathedral
choirs emergency fund that has raised
eight hundred and thirty thousand pounds
after were hopeful million to help
sustain cathedrals at least through
Christmas and Easter well any of the
government's 1.5 billion pounds bail out
for the Arts go towards Cathedral choirs
does the government even see them as
part of the Arts as they surely are
in the past the doctrine of stand on
your own two feet has been ruthlessly
applied to cathedrals far more than to
theaters and opera houses so I'm not
very hopeful
we need our choirs back cathedrals are
vast singers can stand far apart from
each other in a semi-circle it's time
for common sense to take charge that's
what you send a Maxton Graham and that's
it from spectator out loud this week
thanks for listening thanks to our
producer Cindi you and if anyone has got
comments about this or any other podcast
that we do please email them because
it's always great to hear from you it's
a spectator no it's what is it's in the
podcast a spectator dot Scott you came
[Music]
get 12 weeks of The Spectator in print
and online for just 12 pounds and will
give you a 20 pound Amazon gift voucher
absolutely free go to spectator coat UK
forward slash voucher voucher